close this rubbish goes the cry outside
a tv station in kiev
it's linked to a politician who the uk
claimed was being considered by russia
as a possible puppet leader of ukraine
yevhen mirajev says he's even received
death threats since britain's foreign
office pointed the finger at him a
fortnight ago so when you were an mp i
guess you worked over there he denies
being a russian agent believes uk and
u.s spy agencies were tricked into
thinking otherwise and wants a
retraction
[Music]
negative
[Music]
if you were
actually being considered by the russian
intelligence services to be
the leader of a government that was
maybe
favorable to moscow
then of course you'd deny it
officials say russia has in place about
70
of the combat power needed to mount a
full-scale invasion with more still
arriving
america's national security adviser says
any attack could take a number of forms
it could happen as soon as tomorrow or
it could take some weeks yet he has put
himself in a position with military
deployments
to be able to act aggressively against
ukraine at any time now
but diplomacy is still in play france's
president off to russia and ukraine
while germany's new leader is bound for
washington
and all the while expect moscow's
military might on display
ibrahim sky news kiev